most firms distinguish different levels
of partner roles so often it starts with
a junior partner level which you will
have for another two years or so until
then you can get elected partner of the
firm this is now this real full partner
role and then after four to 5 years or
so in your partner role you can become a
senior partner but that being said as a
junior partner you can then expect to
earn something about 200 to
250,000 then once you're really getting
elected a full partner this will usually
be above €300,000 in salary this salary
with it increase over time again heavily
also influenced by your performance once
you're a senior partner this can then be
rather around 600 to 800,000 Euro and
indeed the best earning best performing
senior Partners can earn in the millions
so we'll earn several million euro every
year